this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello fellow simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields melbourne and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
let it go let it go
man we were doing karaoke with that the
other night you know the frozen song
oh yeah and ella we we turned on the um
the let it go frozen so they have
karaoke versions of it because there's
karaoke of everything on youtube
yeah on youtube i'm sure yeah and she is
just mesmerized with karaoke now
but today we are going to talk about
letting go letting go of sentimental
items letting go of junk letting go of
anxiety and stress
letting go of anything that harms our
well-being or interrupts our
peace i thought this was the perfect
place to start ryan
you know we've got minimalist.org that's
our 100 local meetup groups there's also
the online
meetup group where thousands of people
post different things and encourage
others to
live a meaningful life with less and
this
post from jess ann really stood out to
me she took a picture
i don't know if you saw this ryan but
her the quote on
this post says i saw this on the way to
work yesterday yeah
there are definitely days when i feel
like my stuff owns
me and you want to describe what's in
the photo
yeah i did see this so this is uh if
someone bought a new car and you know
how it comes with like the
license plate frame and this one came
with
the uh piece of paper to go where the
license plate goes it says proud
new owner of human driver which is yeah
that's great and which is funny
uh because you know we paid for the car
and there's something more there with
like
we paid to be owned oh
yeah it's like when we buy clothes that
have an ostentatious logo there it's
hard to avoid clothes with logos these
days
yeah but when we are paying for the
privilege of advertising
someone else's product or service yeah
so wait do i get a discount for how big
the logo is on this thing maybe
you could you could take a little bit of
the price off anyway
i just thought it was fascinating
because how you talk about truth in
advertising
yeah proud owner of a human this car now
owns you let's talk about why it might
own
you and why it's hard to let go of if
that's the
the theme of today well because it owns
you because now you're making car
payments what is it
dave ramsey says that i think the
average car payment is around 560
dollars a month
and i think the average loan now is
somewhere around
70 or 80 months it's not the 60 month
thing anymore
people are expanding this in fact i
wrote about it and love people use
things the the exact
um stats there i'm just they're just not
at the top of my mind right now but
i'll tell you that now you're tethered
to that car payment and of course
a year from now if you want to sell this
chevy it looks like it's a chevy if you
want to sell it
you're going to be upside down
especially with a long loan rate like
that right yeah
as soon as you drive off the lot it's 10
20 gone like that
yeah but you're still paying for that 10
or 20 percent right
well and then there's other costs too
maintaining the thing changing the oil
and the thing
cleaning the thing replacing parts on
the thing
so yeah i mean that's that's why it ends
up owning you is because
you take more care of that car than that
car
takes care of you oh to a large extent
yeah i mean i remember
thinking like if i could just buy the
fanciest car when i bought my first
lexus it was because i was spending so
much time in my car every day
driving from an exurb into the city
and in doing that what would happen well
i realized like
well i have to work this job so i can
pay for this car that will take me to
this job that will allow me to pay for
this car that will take me to the job
and then it was like maddening it was
like an m.c escher sketch
yeah but it was my life right and i was
so
tied to that car payment so much so that
it wasn't enough and so what i do when i
got a second and third
car payment but there was a point where
my wife and i had
had three cars for the two of us
anyway i ended up getting rid of one
going into more debt to get rid of it
how weird is that in order to get rid of
this thing i have to go into debt
yeah because it wasn't worth what i
had the amount of money i had borrowed
in order to purchase
the the land crew or was a land rover
that i had anyway i saw this other post
and
this is a little meme here that i
disagree with but it sounds
it's what you and i might call a faux
funded so jordan i don't know if there's
a way to show this on the youtube
version here if you can
see that but ryan you want to read this
little meme here at the bottom
the hardest decision in life is deciding
whether to walk away
or try harder that sounds profound
it does sound profound especially in
relationships i can see how that
you know so toxic relationship should i
walk away or should i try harder
so it applies there but i think it also
applies to our stuff
yeah should i walk away or try harder
is this meant to be satire no no it
could be
inspirational and and i like that you
said it because you can see through
things like that
and so you're you're you're an acute
observer of of of these things so when
you see something like that and you're
like
that can't be serious right because
trying harder
is might be an indication that
what the only option is to walk away
here's what i mean by that like
trying harder what if i were to just
change that phrase into like spinning my
wheels
yeah and then all of a sudden you know
should i walk away or spin my wheels
of course and so like it when i'm
thinking about
the amount of effort that goes into
letting go
well you and i both know this letting go
is not something you do it's something
you stop doing
letting go actually doesn't require
effort
it requires that we stop the clinging
right in a way
right yeah i'm trying to look at this
like where would this be
a serious i mean i don't know
like like hobbies it's like sometimes
you know
people get to that point where they're
like am i really passionate about this
yeah or should i just walk away from
this and i think if we're asking that
question
it's already been answered right yeah
does that make sense
there might be a rare exception to that
yeah yeah i think by and large
yeah i could i could totally see that or
you just accept that you're
mildly interested in it like with me and
guitar
i mean i really enjoy playing guitar i'm
not like crazy passionate about it but i
really enjoy playing
right um i don't feel like i need to try
harder or walk away
but it's something that like i'm
certainly not gonna like make a living
from or
right do like an open mic night or
anything like that and you're also not
even compelled to ask that a question
like this about guitar playing yeah
this question wouldn't enter your mind
about guitar playing but if it enters
your mind about
holding on to a particular physical item
yeah i totally agree with that yeah
should i try harder to like this item
or even with a relationship but you know
with the relationship piece of it
sometimes the problem is us like i look
at my past relationships and i didn't
try hard enough
and i probably won and i yeah i probably
walked away in a lot of situations where
but i just didn't have the knowledge i
didn't know what to do yeah
um but yeah you're right like when it
comes to material possessions
what are you gonna do try and i'm gonna
appreciate this more
as soon as you i'm gonna give it more
sentimentality right right as soon as
you start saying those things out loud
it really highlights the absurdity yeah
in the clinging
the relationship thing is interesting
i'd like to have a maybe we can save
that for
the maximal episode over on patreon this
thursday
we could talk about the relationship
thing because i i would
actually argue that it wasn't about
trying in those relationships we'll
leave it at that for
now because we got some really important
questions sure
chris in boston has a question for us
boston's very expensive and i have to
move again and i'm moving into a place i
can afford but it's a lot smaller and
i've been doing the minimalism challenge
for a few
months now and i can definitely see a
difference
but not a difference that is enough to
move into this new place
and i'm finding the pace of doing the
minimalism challenge or the northern
as very helpful and very good for me
i've tried a bunch of things in the past
that haven't worked
but i'm curious on your thoughts of
like getting a storage unit and staying
at this pace
ways to maybe pick up the pace without
it getting overwhelming
um i have to move by april 1st
so ryan you're well versed in moving and
even as a minimalist
it still kind of sucks in a way right oh
yeah moving is like one of the worst
things
it's funny because i'll have friends
i'll i'll say i'm moving and i have
friends who are like oh i'll help you
move and i'm i'm always like
you're my friend i want that to continue
to be the truth
right like why would i ever put the
burden of moving on to you
yeah i think that works until you're
about 29. that's my past yeah that's my
passive-aggressive way of saying
when it's time for you to move don't
come to me and ask me to help you move
no i'm of the same mind now with chris's
question in particular what she's saying
is
hey i'm experiencing wonderful benefits
from decluttering from simplifying from
letting go of excess material
possessions
it's not happening fast enough now you
and i have different stories for folks
who have seen lessons now
they know that it took me about eight
months to radically simplify my life and
chris is saying
i don't have eight months to get rid of
80 90 of my material possessions
i have to move relatively soon and so
i look toward ryan here and say well
ryan's packing
21 day packing party you're actually
going through this ryan's idea for the
packing party was
hey the time that we are forced to
confront all of our things is when we
are moving that's still true even as
minimalist we have to confront all of
our things
when we are moving and so
the packing party was a way to
manufacture that because ryan wasn't
actually
moving you are moving so you by
definition are embarking on a packing
party
the key isn't to unpack everything
immediately as soon as you get there in
fact
if anything i love chris's idea about
the storage unit ryan
this is one of the rare cases where i
would say a storage unit makes sense and
here's why
yeah tell me why because i would put a
deadline on and i would pay in advance
hey here's here's my 30-day or 60-day
storage unit pay for the full thing in
advance by the end of that i'm done i'm
not going to extend this any further
okay
and then i'm only gonna i would move
everything that i'm
not certain i'm going to use so
basically only the essentials and the
the absolute uh non-essentials like a
couch or something you know you're going
to hold on to
i would move in the the actual move but
everything else even i was kind of like
i'll probably use that
i'm gonna put it in the storage locker
and i'm gonna i'm creating the
additional friction
because those things are owning you
right now and for a weird
in a weird way i want them to own you
more for the next 30 to 60 days
because if they own you more you're
gonna realize that tug they have on your
life and you're
it's going to compel you to not
re-clutter your space in the future the
letting go
is important but the of the continuing
to to not
cling after you've like let go is i
think equally important so you're saying
that
if things are in the storage unit chris
is at
her place uh and she finds herself
basically
being like oh man where's that broken
waffle ireland i really want that right
now
right i mean i know that's probably
she's not keeping broken waffles waffle
iron
yeah yeah so so it's really it's kind of
like a packing party with additional
friction
almost yeah interesting um
a piece of me wants to tell chris
uh make a pile of everything that's
going to go in the storage unit
and that's the pile that you know you
need to let go of
because because there are all those
things in the storage union are really
kind of a just-in-case
thing yeah um but i i do like yeah i
chris we're not here to give advice
we're just here to talk about what we
would do
yeah personally i personally i do the
packing party because that's what i've
done in the past
so i would just forego the storage unit
and i would just
you know everything that's left over
bring to my place and be
overwhelmed by all that stuff and unpack
things as i need it
and then yeah set a deadline um if you
want to create the additional friction
with a storage unit great
chris we give you permission to do
whatever you want yeah right i love the
idea of the piles
because what you're echoing there and by
the way chris let's send you a copy of
the minimalist rule book
folks listening to this you can download
it for free the minimalist rule book
i'm sorry it's the minimalist.com
rulebook where you can find there's also
an audiobook version so chris if you
want that we'll send it to you but
there's a few rules in there
and what you can do because these rules
are so tailor-able
right they're not off the rack and so
you get to adjust them
and in this one of those cases usually
we we often tell people hey if the 90-90
rule is too strict for you
make it the one-year one-year rule but
for you
chris this might be one of those rare
instances where it's like all right
let's get really aggressive
this is the 30 30 or 35 35 rule whatever
it is
yeah and you're going to to make those
constraints a little bit more definitive
because
they're going to serve you in this
shortened period of time but there's one
rule in there called the no junk rule
everything you own can fit in one of
three piles either it's either
essential truly essential or it's
non-essential
or it's junk so essentials we all have
pretty much the same essentials
food clothing shelter education vocation
transportation
and those things are pretty much
universal there's a few
exceptions there but and by the way
don't confuse education with schooling
don't confuse
transportation with a car loan don't
confuse
vocation with um with um
a job that you hate so so all of those
things you know have caveats as well
but set that aside the non-essentials
the couch the the dining room table
these are things that add value to my
life i use them regularly
great i don't absolutely need them but
they serve me
of course move those things with you as
well but that third pile is what ryan is
talking about here he's talking about
that junk pile
yeah ryan i used to call this the need
want like list and it's it's kind of
deceptive because the likes are like
well yeah i kind of like that
but it's actually getting in the way
it's not serving you
right and so like yeah yeah that would
be nice in some ideal hypothetical world
that doesn't actually exist
but when we're honest with ourselves we
realize like oh no
50 60 70 80 of my stuff
is junk isn't that hard to admit too
when you were going through the packing
party ryan yeah
it's like oh my god what have i done
yeah well you know you have space for it
so you just you fill the space
and that sounds like where chris is at
and now she's moving into a smaller
space
and confronted with all that junk that
she's collected throughout the years
um yeah best of luck chris i
i think i think she uh i will say
i thought she could double the
minimalism game
so maybe on day one it's one thing and
then on day two it's four things and
then on day three it's six things
i mean she really needs to like get more
momentum i'm just multiply because i
think if you multiplied it
like if you doubled every day i saw i
thought you're saying it first oh i
think you end up getting rid of a
billion things yeah no no you just
double the day so i guess on day one it
would be two things
yeah yeah cool anyway um yeah but you
know the fact that chris has already got
this momentum going that's outstanding
yes and uh yeah i mean it's again we're
not here to give advice
but we are here to give you permission
to do whatever you want chris and this
smaller living space will allow her
to not re-clutter as easily
i was just talking to someone on i do
this little solo podcast called
minimalism today over on
our patreon uh patreon.com the
minimalists by the way every monday i
just
call up someone and we just talk about
something and i was talking to this
woman
about the exact opposite of this i moved
into a bigger house that made
sense and now i'm afraid
that because i feel compelled to fill
all
the spaces right yeah we buy a 4 000
square foot house
we feel empty if the house is empty of
course we're not
empty and trying to fill ourselves with
by filling the house is always a
fruitless
pursuit and so it's nice that you're
finding an appropriate space for you
now it's finding the appropriate amount
of items to fill that space
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for our lightning round
where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to 937-202-4654
one day i'm gonna memorize that number
instead of having to read it up as well
it does go to both of our phones so
i dip in there dip my toe in the waters
occasionally and answer people's
questions we also answer some on the
podcast now during the lightning round
this is where ryan and i do our best
answer every question with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share
our pithy answers on social media if
you'd like ryan we got a question here
from james
all right when the amount of your
belongings
is completely overwhelming how and where
do you even start here's my pithy answer
maybe we could talk about it ryan
the y is the starting point
the how is the finish line
okay so i i the question has a win in it
it has
a hal and it has a where
right but the why is the actual starting
line now
i think you have a piece of the y here
you're overwhelmed
but i think right now you're only
intellectually overwhelmed
yeah and that's still overwhelming and
so by being intellectually overwhelmed
there's a lot of shoulds
what you're telling yourself is i should
simplify i should
let go letting go isn't prescriptive
right right if you go outside ryan
and you pick up a a
thorny cactus there's like a it's laying
on the ground you pick it up
and it's hurting you mm-hmm you don't
need the how to let go of the cactus
right you understand viscerally
that you must let go and you simply drop
it not out of prescription no one told
you
ryan you have to drop that cactus no no
that wasn't that wasn't required
but of course the how to ryan we can we
can talk about some of the how-to things
sure about how how to start or or when
to start
where to start but always start with the
why how might my life be better with
less without this item understanding
that deeply and viscerally
the letting go becomes so much easier
yeah
oh man yeah it's it's interesting people
are they're just looking for the how to
because they are so over overwhelmed so
they want the recipe it's like you know
if i wanted to bake a cake
i would look for the recipe sure where's
the recipe um
however two things if it was my first
cake
that i was baking i'm probably gonna
screw it up so even if i had the recipe
i'm not gonna do it correctly
and then let's say i did it perfectly i
might not that might not be my favorite
flavor of cake
right now i just want to eat cake can we
extend this analogy a little bit farther
sure ryan because i
i think it's great is that if you're
truly
hungry you're not even going to need the
recipe for cake you're going to find a
way to
nourish yourself the cake is is
you know and of course the icing on the
cake as as we say right
it's it's everything else after we've
we've we've done what we need to do
anyway i'm sure you've got some of the
pithy for us
yeah my pithy answer is this a life
without boundaries is a life without
peace
so james here's the thing is
you're overwhelmed because you haven't
set up the appropriate boundaries
so you know once you get past the why
once you answer that question how might
your life be better with less
you have to get clear on what you're
what on what you want your life to look
like so going back to the minimalist
rule book that'd be a great place to
start james
you can uh adapt for your life
uh those rules you you can you can edit
them a little bit
um the rules that we have laid out it's
for josh and i it's not for you per se
if you take all of our rules up and
you're like these are the perfect rules
for me also great that's
outstanding you're not going to get a
certificate or anything
but the key is is like you have to set
up some boundaries
and then here's the third and most
important part i feel
is you got to take action if you don't
take the action james
doesn't matter what what you know
self-help book you read
you have to take action and i think
going back to the baking
the cake analogy people are scared to
start
because they're scared of failing
they're scared of it not working the way
that they intended it to
and yeah i guess you know that's my way
of just giving james or anyone else out
there permission
to screw it up start and screw up and
learn from it and then start again
the cake actually really highlights that
because no one's really afraid of baking
a cake
right but when it becomes these higher
stake items like higher stakes items
like
letting go of your stuff or ending a
relationship
or dealing with sentimental items i mean
i think about that
yeah getting rid of some of my mom's
stuff uh that produced
initially a lot of anxiety and stress
and overwhelm in me and james is talking
about
how overwhelming this process is baking
a cake generally isn't
overwhelming well why isn't it
overwhelming it would be if you had
never heard of cake before
yeah and you had never been in a kitchen
before sure
if you're some tribal person who was
just brought into a kitchen and
you're going to be overwhelmed but
it quickly becomes not overwhelming
because
there is a recipe and the recipe isn't
just the ingredients there's a sequence
of events there as well and so
things like the minimalist rule book we
give you a recipe
and you can adjust it for your own
taste yeah by the way i know this is
going to be we're going to talk more
about this on our right here right now
segment a little bit later on because we
have some additional recipes that we
would like
to share with you and before we get into
that before we get into our listener
comments and our added value segment
today it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like a lot
of surprise questions this week
what is maximalism and when is it better
than minimalism what are some effective
ways to stop
impulse buying how do i convince my
spouse's family to stop giving us
stuff without upsetting anyone and a
million more questions about
letting go for the minimalists and if
you want to hear all that listen to this
week's maximal episode on patreon that's
right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each thursday ryan
and i record a much longer maximal
episode
on the minimalists private podcast visit
the minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app
if you enjoy our show and want to
support the minimalists this is the only
way
our podcast earns money it's cheaper
than a cup of coffee
and it keeps our show 100 advertisement
free
plus private podcast subscribers also
gain access to hundreds of hours of
archives
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners check them
out hey minimalists
my name is emma calling from mammoth
lakes california
i recently listened to your episode
on social media and i had a great tip
for people who were looking to
cut back their use of social media
whether it be
for time spent using it or
just the fact that getting
caught up with social media is taken
away from
the other things in their life that are
bringing them value
one thing i have done to cut back my use
of social media
is gone to my settings of my phone and
turned
off cellular use data for
certain apps so for example if i want to
cut back my time spent on facebook
i can go to my cellular use
area of my settings and turn off
cellular data for that app meaning i can
only access
that app if i'm attack
if i'm connected to internet and
i've done this for most of my social
media apps
just because it cuts back how much i use
them
and allows me to a save some of my data
because i don't like going over and
having to spend more money
but also just not using the apps as much
as i used to
this is joe from dallas and this was a
comment for
some parents who have trouble with all
the
things that their kids have and don't
necessarily want to throw away
their children's things without
permission from their children or
talking to their kids about it
we had a playroom that was exploding
with toys and
what we did was we adapted the
minimalism game
for our kids and so we asked them what
motivated them
and they talked about getting new toys
so we decided we
were going to let them do it for a month
and for every number that they got to
on their game we would give them ten
dollars at the end of the month
to spend so the first toy they got rid
of they got ten dollars and then
to get to number two they'd give away
two toys and they'd be at twenty dollars
and then three toys and
so it'd be six toys total and they'd be
at 30. just like the minimalism game
but we didn't go by days we just let
them go as the month went on
my i underestimated my children they
each got to 13
toys which was over 90 and really over
100 because
they got through they got rid of some
collections of toys like plastic
dinosaur collection would be one toy
and uh so i owed them 260 dollars
to go on a shopping spree and instead of
buying 13 toys each they uh they pulled
their money and they bought three toys
that they really wanted
and uh so i traded in 200 toys for three
toys and in one month we
really got rid of a big chunk of that
playroom
and uh on a whim after we went on our
shopping spree for the three items i
drew 91 smiley faces on a napkin to show
my daughter
and i said this is how many kids that
you made happy this month
and uh for those that are worried about
consumerism or or
teaching their kids that you know the
the reward for doing well
is to go on a shopping spree when they
had a playdate a few days later
and they brought their friends to their
playroom it wasn't the new toys that
they went to they had
kept the napkin and they showed their
friends that
you know they were so proud of how many
kids that they had made happy this month
and we've had it continue to go for the
last couple of months
and we have drastically reduced the
amount of toys that we have in the house
and the kids have toys that they really
really wanted and that they
they were invested in because they got
to choose them themselves i hope this
helps
some families out there it's been very
helpful for us
all right y'all for our added value this
week ryan jonesy just came out with a
new album oh cool
it's called shiver the album is and
since we're talking about letting go
today the first song is called exhale
and some of the lyrics are about letting
it go but it is so
it's powerful and i know we can't play
this on youtube if you're watching this
on youtube but if you're listening to
the audio version
we'll play out with jonesy's new song
called exhale but
if you are on youtube check out the
video for this it is a
gorgeous gorgeous video i mean jordan
inspiration for future episodes
i mean i don't know how we would
actually accomplish what he's done in
this video
it's rather avant-garde but it is
astonishing and the song
is so just powerful like i felt it down
in my bone marrow about letting go it's
like
the let it go song from frozen but all
grown up and introspective
and existentialist in a way it's jonesy
it's called exhale cool from his album
shiver by the way ryan um
this this speaking of exhaling
2020 was a difficult year for a lot of
people
financially right yeah um and it was
certainly a difficult year for us we had
quite a few months we're going to talk
about this on the maximum episode
today we had quite a few months for the
first time i think ever where we were
an unprofitable business last year i
think it was 9 out of 12 months
last year as a result and there are a
few reasons for that we'll get into it
on
the maximal episode wait a minute i saw
on the internet that we're worth 124
million dollars
mean to tell me the internet's wrong i
think they've misplaced a decimal point
in there
[Laughter]
at the very very beginning oh my god
anyway yeah and so
we're fine and in fact by the way we we
didn't lay anyone off everyone who works
with us
made sure we they got paid every every
month even
year in bonuses everything like that but
we did
raise our we removed our patreon cap on
we have three tiers of
of patrons for our private podcast there
is the two dollar tier the five dollars
here
and the eight dollar chairs two dollars
here is just the private podcast here
you get the audio feed
for the um true fans which is there's a
thousand true fans that cap is still
there that's the five dollar tier you
get
live events you get ask the minimalist
anything
and then we have the vip tier which is
250 people that still has a cap
as well and so those caps are staying in
place there we did
temporarily remove the cap on our two
dollar patreon so if you do want to get
in there now's a great time to do it i
think there's still about a hundred
spots left on the the true fan
tier as well if you want a video version
of the private podcast you want
a bunch of our archives of live events
they're
all in there as well but on the maximum
episode today we're going to talk about
some of those
money problems that even you and i have
when uh there's
an unexpected pandemic yeah different
from an expected pandemic
and i would argue that this was kind of
expected oh yeah
so we're not gonna talk about the
pandemic necessarily but we will talk
about
some of the financial things that we've
done and and some of the ways that we've
been harmed by the pandemic there were
quite a few ways i count five or six
that i wrote down
of ways that we were harmed financially
by the pandemic and
how we sort of were able to navigate
that without any panic without any worry
yeah and we want to thank you if you are
one of the podcast supporters because we
are going to keep this
100 advertisement free that would be a
way for us to
quickly be profitable it's so funny
because like when i hear
yeah it would be i totally agree with
you and we would never be able to
forgive ourselves
um but you know i uh
i think about other podcasters who ask
for the two dollars for
the patreon and i feel and i do support
a lot of people with a dollar or two
dollars um
there's like this thing where i'm like
oh that's not very much but being on
this end of it
yeah and asking for the two bucks it is
everything man right it is everything
so um yeah i uh if you only if you give
us only two dollars a month for the
podcast and you're uh
that's all you can afford like that if
you can't afford anything that's great
too we appreciate you listening but the
two dollars it really does go a long way
and we can't thank you enough for it yes
indeed
thank you so much real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist
on youtube
we have three seasons ryan and i did
this series called living room
conversations so
if you are a new listener and you have a
question
my guess is if you go to our youtube
channel it's just youtube.com
the minimalist we probably answered a
similar question
in there's 60 videos there 60 episodes
of living room conversations oh wow
that we you and i did and we answered a
bunch of different questions about
simple living about relationships about
books that were inspirational about
getting out of debt about
budgeting about minimalism with a family
i did a video with
ella and the question was how many toys
should a minimalist kid have
and she answered that question with me
it was super super cute
this was a few years ago that we did
that one anyway uh there's
60 different videos on our youtube
channel called living room conversations
and who knows we might even get renewed
for a fourth season ryan
let's talk jordan into it maybe right
but we had a lot of fun recording those
if you want to check those out three
seasons of living room conversations
over at youtube.com
minimalist by the way our youtube
channel 100
advertisement free we don't run any
pre-roll ads if you ever see an
ad on our youtube channel it means
someone has copyright claimed one of our
videos and we still work
like if we put a piece of music
accidentally or something plays
that's very rarely happened it's
happened to maybe three of our videos
ever
but but we work hard to make sure that
doesn't happen because we don't want
any ads yeah you already see 10 000
advertisements a day we don't want to be
the ones who
who bring forth 10 000 1 advertisements
to your life
yeah you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple
sunday emails whenever we send those and
if you leave here today
with just one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it